[Music]
why are
no cats in breath the wild don't get me
wrong i love dogs
dogs are awesome but you can't have dogs
without cats there's a reason why the
phrase like cat and dog exists
they are two sides of the same coin yin
and yang the balance of the cosmos
take away one and the universe spirals
into absolute chaos
it's no wonder the world ended in breath
the wild ganondorf was like
what no cats
ocarina of time had dogs but no cats
same goes for majora's mask
oh wait is this a cat no it's a fox the
wind waker had neither cats or dogs and
instead resorted to pigs which are cool
but they're no cats or dogs twilight
princesses cats and dogs which is why
it's the best game ever made it's also
the only game where they actually kill
ganondorf once and for all
skyward sword had cats demon cats but
cats nonetheless
but again no dogs lake's awakening is
like the mvp of animals it has dogs
chickens rabbits hippos weird furry lamb
women crocodiles walruses you name it
but guess what
no cats i know the island is supposed to
be a dream but what the wingfish
couldn't have dreamt up some cats and of
course breath the wild
only has dogs it's no surprise that the
world of zelda is always in a perpetual
state of war chaos and suffering
timeline splits armageddon giant floods
evil curses all because somehow this
world refuses to have the two most
important species co-exist in the same
universe
if we want breath of the wild too to
have a happy ending it is of utmost
importance that cats make a return
lots of cats cats everywhere by the way
did you know there's an island in japan
inhabited almost entirely by cats
come on nintendo you have the technology
science shows it can be done
stop torturing the poor people of this
world cats are an essential
counterweight to dogs
which are awesome did i mention dogs are
awesome i don't believe you
in the meantime i call upon the entire
breath wild modding community to step in
and stabilize this situation
please turn dogs into cats but not all
dogs because then we only have cats and
no dogs and we're back to square one
only certain dogs should be turned into
cats
people have been inserting cats into
pulp fiction breaking bad lord of the
rings the matrix
it is your responsibility as a modder to
make this happen
as for the rest of us let our voices be
heard hashtag bring their cats in the
legend of zelda breath a while too am i
tired of saying the word cats
in fact i am not cats cats cats cats
cats cats
cats now some of you might be wondering
why would i upload such a weird and
random video
and the reason is